Anna Kendrick opens up about her
sexuality and what it was like to kiss
Blake Lively yo Ryan Reynolds you better
watch your back and it's coming for your
lady and I'm Blake co-star in the
upcoming movie a simple favor where the
two shared kiss pride snorts that all
she ever thinks about before kissing
scene is who has gum who has a mint and
apparently Blake was the same quote so
we were the mint tea as fresh as two
people to have ever kiss in the history
of America called Guinness she added
that it was a fun game now we know these
two love each other in fact Blake
herself made a simple pass at Anna on
Instagram you have said that Anna is
like the the hotter female version of
your husband so what kind of Ryan like
quality does she possess I know a lot of
guys that would be fine with that but
not me I would like to hang on to her
yeah please let's not do that I can't
think of sighs I mean she would be so
well taken care of with Anna though I
think you know that's got the got the
goods
yeah no hide your kids hide your wife
Ryan
all right so Anna may not be wrecking
the Reynolds home anytime soon but she
didn't get candid about dipping her toe
in the lady pond
she told pride source that she was more
like Blake's character in the movie
someone who is very comfortable with the
fluid aspects of her sexuality quote I
think I haven't had that emotional love
for a lady which isn't sane it could
never happen to me Anna you are truly
evolved never change ki t all right
switching gears now to another high
profile couple Beyonce and jay-z they've
been on the run and last night got a
real scare from the stage crasher
[Music]
the man rush in the stage was later
identified as 26 year old Anthony
Maxwell security quickly stopped the
suspect in his path and these backup
dancers ran after the guy - it looks
like they also helped apprehend him
there's a closer look and the chaos that
ensued
the Atlanta Police Department tells ET
Maxwell quote had in fact made contact
with jay-z the suspect sustained minor
injuries but no one else was hurt but he
was arrested and transported to an
Atlanta County Jail where he was charged
with battery and disorderly conduct
Beyonce's rep posted this photo from the
show and wrote thank you to all the fans
for your concern they are fine and
looking forward to the show tomorrow and
I just love how the dancers swarmed the
dude like bees guys don't mess with the
hive you'll get the sting I mean while
it was a big little lies were Union at
another concert Reese Witherspoon rocked
out with Nicole Kidman at her hubby
Keith Urban show in Nashville the two
pose for a photo backstage and I think
Reese's are Keith's groupie y'all
about me okay few songs a bigoted song
dreams yes if you were a singer this
race while Ries hung with Keith and
Nicole across town on Saturday check out
who shared the stage with Taylor Swift
[Music]
[Applause]
tim mcgraw and wife feed he'll sink
Taylor's first ever hit Tim McGraw in
Nashville where it all started for
little Taylor and you know what we've
been with her since that beginning look
what I found in the ET boat y'all the
fact that it's become a hit for me and
you know propelled with my career so far
it's just so amazing I'm so grateful
this time last year you know I was just
coming here and basically observing and
this year I'm nominated and performing
and that there's no better feeling you
done good kid I think it's safe to say
she's done real well for herself since
then all right guys that's it for today
be sure to like and share this video and
I'll be back tomorrow with another day
Danny